- [Gary] Uh-oh.
- [Man] Ok.
- Told you.
- Two minutes.
- Alright. Okay.
Why do we stop here and move it?
Let's move it, let's
move it, let's move it.
We're fine. Move.
No reason to fight.
(rock music)
Feeling' really good
today. Tough flight.
The 7 PM New York to
Europe is tough because
you're timing's off.
Had three different sessions
of two, three hour sleeps.
Got it in.
Dublin's a gorgeous town.
Get in there, brother.
It's gorgeous.
Really enjoying my stay so far.
Had some productive meetings.
What's kind of cool right now,
over here DRock,
what's kinda cool right now
with VaynerMedia UK
opening, Europe is in play so
I always say I love being
Gary Vaynerchuk CEO
and I play GaryVee.
Any time I'm in GaryVee mode
which is once every three years
for three or four weeks when I'm
doing book stuff, I struggle with
that because is not my
favorite zone believe it or not.
I want to be in my operating
mode and so being able to do the
meetings that I just did
that are more predicated on
VaynerMedia's growth
in the European market.
They would strategize
and say videos.
and say infographics.
They would strategize and
say audio podcasts.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- They would strategize and then
we would produce
and then we deploy.
- [Woman] Yeah. Okay.
- It's kind of interesting.
I think is really fascinating
that the two places that most
people are cynical around
social media, B-to-B and
performance-based is it
black-and-white ROI,
are the two places that we as a
company are most confident in.
You're going to
go project manage
the building of a consumer app?
- 100% can't do it.
That was loaded.
I was in a great zone.
God, there was a lot there.
I have a really
interesting idea.
I literally think
something titled
"Jam Session with GaryVee"
could be an unbelievable.
People are selling hard work
without actually doing it.
- [Woman] Absolutely.
- It's really easy
to tweet hustle.
It's a whole different
thing to actually do it.
As video is evolving and as
my career is evolving and
technology is evolving a long
time ago I said it was going to
be harder and harder to hide.
I think this is not a joke,
one of the reasons why I'm
aggressively storytelling with
having a man follow me around
and videotape and now with
Snapchat is I want to pressure
the other people in
this space to show me.
Show me.
- Could you do a video?
- Yeah.
- Basically as my
alarm in the morning.
- Yes, you saw that?
- Absolutely on fire.
- Cameron, Cameron,
Cameron it's GaryVee.
Get the fuck up my man.
Cam let's get this, Cam.
Let's get this today.
One life, baby.
One life, Cameron.
- Best take ever.
- You got it brother. Pleasure.
- Thank you.
Stay well. Take care.
All right DRock.
- Bro, how are you?
- Good to see you.
- You're brilliant.
You really are.
- Thank you. Thank you
so much thank you.
Now I can feel with no heavy
conscience now I can go on stage
and rip and I mean rip
everybody's faces
off here in Dublin.
Who's an entrepreneur in here?
Raise your hand.
Let me give you one really,
really good piece of advice.
Speed is 4 billion times
more important than perfection.
The amount of you that are
crippled by getting shit right
instead of getting
shit done is insane.
And it is an absolute
variable to success in an
entrepreneur-land where you have
to do something in those couple
years or your fucking dead.
The selfies I don't know if
you're going to use it, DRock,
they are the selfie
thing is out of control.
- Nice to meet you.
What your name?
- Mary Kate.
- Mary Kate, how are you?
- Good. Very good.
- Good, so nice to meet you.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Yeah.
- A video?
I thought I was
going to be a picture.
You tricked me.
- Thank you.
- Awesome. Bye-bye.
- There we go.
- Awesome thanks
Claire, bye-bye.
You got it, you got it.
Once you open up
Pandora's box, right?
- You're a heart
among the hattles.
- Thank you, man.
Thank you.
You want a picture?
- I want that on DailyVee.
- You got it.
- Yeah?
It's a done deal.
DRock approved.
- DailyVee my man.
- What's his name?
- Connor.
- We call you his pope.
- Connor, it's GaryVee
a.k.a. the Pope.
Super pumped to see
you in a little bit.
Your homies are here.
Just a lot of fun.
I'm going to make a promise on
DailyVee right now never when
I buy the Jets and have to stand
in the stadium for 74,000 strong
selfie it up after we
win the Super Bowl.
It's so crazy to be a big
deal and you know in Ireland.
I will never ever ever ever ever
ever ever not be grateful and
humbled and blown away by
people's respect and admiration
and take a
microsecond to take a selfie.
I just got off the plane
and there was a kid drove
hours to pitch me.
I was in no mood to be pitched
even I kind of answered first.
He's like, "Hey can I tell you?"
I was like "Not now."
Can I get to the hotel?
He's like I drove I don't know
and I was like fine let's do it.
So that's an interesting that's
been intense the love has been
amazing here in Dublin.
Great tech scene a lot of
entrepreneurial spirit.
I love my trip to Sydney, Sydney
I love you, but I be lying if I
didn't say I felt some
unique energy so far.
Maybe that's because I'm
a little more out about
than I was in Sydney.
I don't want anybody
in Australia pissed.
Let's go do it, DRock.
- Very good.
- Pumped?
- Pumped, real good show.
- Cool.
- Go get this done?
- Yeah let's go do it.
- Yeah? Cool.
- Let's go.
Thanks for coming guys.
I love it.
- You like it?
- I love it. It's gorgeous.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 192
of the #AskGaryVee show.
Live from Dublin.
- Uh-oh.
- Okay.
- Told you.
- Two minutes.
- Okay.
- Two minutes, we're fine.
- Why do we stop here move it?
Let's move it,
let's move it, let's move it.
We're fine. Move.
No reason to fight.
(engine running)
- Is he able to get out?
- Yeah, it's looking like it.
- On this episode I
go in The Startup Van.
Awesome.
- Brilliant.
- Great.
- All cool.
- Cool.
- Awesome. Stay well guys.
Stay well guys.
Were you in the talk?
- Yeah.
- Remember when I said
stop doing perfect, do fast?
- Mhmmm.
- Send your work to
everybody who's in the business.
I sat in my store for 12 hours
a day and answered every single
fucking person's wine question.
- Just do it, yeah.
- I guarantee it, I can taste
it, you never set for 12 hours
on Twitter and hit up
everybody. I did every day.
Do you understand?
- I understand.
- Do you understand?
Like literally every day.
Steve Spielberg, hey.
Fucking I don't know.
Quentin Tarantino, hey.
And in the thousand people
that I don't know but
you know the game.
Do you understand?
- Yeah.
- Thanks for coming bro.
- Did they kidnap you?
- What?
- Not yet.
Can you get Alex?
Can you get Alex to get
my bags in The Startup Van?
we're going to have to be tight.
Yeah, no, I know.
- [Man] How you doing?
- Doing super well, brother.
Thanks are some of your tweets.
- Nice.
- Pleasure man.
Thanks for doing that
for us back in the day.
Thanks for having here.
Sup guys? It's GaryVee.
Jim Bellinare and
are that's what we do, huh?
- Get on it.
- Get on.
- Thanks.
- Stay well.
- One last boomerang, I swear.
- You got it. No worries.
- Thank you so much.
- Awesome. Take care.
Bye guys.
- Set up you just
gotta walk right in.
Awesome.
Stay well.
Do I have my phone?
Yeah.
Do I have my passport,
more importantly?
Yeah.
(triumphant rock music)
- [Gary] Great day in Dublin.
Just got to Heathrow.
Were in Heathrow, right Er?
Heathrow. London.
Bringing the fire.
Big time.
DRock, you're going to need
to look at what I just saw.
- [Man] Oh fuck.
- [Gary] Fuck.
Hello everybody!
Yo!
Yeah!
Holy fuck.
(triumphant rock music)